Oh
she looked up she was like sorry for
doing a good job only really suck dick
I'm a lesbian I was like oh
this is not happening I'm going with
junior we all come from somewhere from
someone who nurtures us protects us and
teaches us some better than others
[Music]
a very important day in my life day I
found out my dad smoked crack no young
dude a couple years into my teens naive
ain't even Kirsten I still prayed before
every meal its back when prayers were
short I mean when he was young how short
prayers were before a life kicked in you
needed to pray for motion its back then
you know wholesome young man went to
visit my dad anthems Georgia I remember
getting that phone call I got excited
cuz I seen my dad in two years he was in
a mental institution
he just got out he was about to put the
world on his ass and he was like yo
mouth let's kick it
I got excited with the Athens Georgia
you know he just got this brand new
coupe Cukor below was dope this
plush smelt like cigarettes it was used
as hell but they don't matter cuz he was
fresh out of the mental home you know
know when I've seen the coupe I was like
this by the beat Toby made plans
any time make plans a man make plans are
kicking with his kids that's special
wait no go get something to eat don't go
to the movies if you go to sleep early I
don't get me something no one dudes talk
low like that that's what all the fun
happen I gonna drop you off
dude start talking in wing-dings you
know he's put in his pocket pulled out
$30 gave it to me I was like oh
this nigga doing it ain't never had $30
before you not me there's a lot of money
for a nigga that just gift somebody
that's how I felt it just gave me $30 he
doing it to bills about 20 Antion
I was on top of the world I put that
in my pocket don't disappear we get
in the car right they go all of a sudden
see this is zombie walking down the
street but he just got bit like a phrase
on me by like other he still can walk a
little bit but he's just got a limp not
fools on me but he like yeah but like
like you know this before I knew what a
drug thing was you know with God just
was stumbling like uh like help me get
off the street it was one of those guys
ain't done dad yo what's up man hey
rummy up to the street now I can't run
you up to the street today I got my song
with me funds to go to the movies man
come on man run me off the street to
show the house I was like oh
anytime you know you a young kid and
adult come you like oh you start to get
a little jealous because you know
whatever they swing dinging over there
can get throw me out the game so we hop
in the car we go around the corner right
place called Rock Springs
it's projects but I ain't know at first
we saw the builders I was like there's
the project so my instinct said that's
some real ain't nobody instincts
politically correct that
tell you straight like it is niggas it's
the project
okay what nationality is you see some
sketchy honest things gonna be like they
got that rapist we went
into this house next to the projects
scary house one of house with everything
made noise when you got inside
everything was scared the door the floor
the Rope the light was dim the light was
scared to go in that bitch the light was
creep in there like what y'all niggas
doing in here and I'm like man get in
there I need you to see come on in
that's what the lady said come on in
door yeah late in the kitchen cooking
don't crack I don't know if you ever
smelled crack before but it smelled like
alumina for taste you have a taste in
long before never you never like try to
get like a fake grill and put a foil
around so you can start on them all okay
anyway you know I mean you got that got
that taste to it you tasted in an
airline oh you know something wrong even
as a youth there's lady turn around she
was like wait oh yeah three y'all want
something dance like no this is my son
and I was like oh I up do I
look she think I'm one of these dough's
that's what I was over I'm like man I
need to get out of here and I looked and
it was a back door open and it had a
basketball right outside but in the
projects they had a basketball court so
that was my excuse it's like a universe
was telling me get the out of here
so I was like hey Dad
I wanna go play basketball he's like hey
won't you go play basketball like it was
his idea like he thought of it
so I grab the ball and I go outside and
it was scary and cuz I had to cross
the threshold into the projects now if
you don't live in the projects you don't
got no business in the goddamn projects
and the only people I knew that lived in
the projects one of them died
so who the I'm a year for so I
tried to be tough walking in the
projects go shoot basketball but guess
what I can't play goddamn basketball I
stopped that basketball got cut from
everything I tried out for and people
looking at me like who the this
nigga that's what they do when you walk
in any hood and they don't know you
this these lawyers shorts
off I shoot a ball air ball miss I just
watch the ball just miss and I'm like oh
I better get my ass work I'm not
trying to shoot I'm nervous
any time somebody make a move I'm doing
this all of a sudden my dad come outside
hey hey what's up man oh you playing
basketball let me see that ball Pein he
missed but he didn't give a about
playing basketball he just turned at me
and I saw her look at his eyes and it
was intense it was intense
ain't even recognized he's like hey man
you got that $20 I gave you know yeah I
got it but that was deep I'm not
used to having $30 I'm giving this dude
75% of my money I don't even know if
it's 75% is ending up a had 30 goddamn
dollars before I even do the math and
I'm reaching that that was folding
so tight like the last two pieces of
toilet paper you know you fold that
it was deep like I had to unfold it to
see what it is I was like yeah here it
is right here
he's I I'll be back and he just like
dances hands away you know I mean and
I'm feeling bad now cuz I'm like man I
don't miss dinner oh my all right we
still won't go to the movies you know I
mean we still might get breaking the
ball boom people going around talk I'm
talking to him a little bit nervous as
my dad come back ten minutes later
hey man you got the other team I was
like no no I must have dropped that
[Music]
all right all right I'll be back you're
good you're good
and then he left right he left I was
like man he started hit me like man I
think my dad own Troggs man if he was on
trials that'll be up like I'm
bout to miss a movie now I don't drove
an hour
dammit ain't gonna get to see arrows
Family Values you don't mean I shoot a
shot just as I miss this is our air ball
you see the ball uh and I see the blue
Cougars just drive off and I'm like oh
this nigga just left me in the projects
by myself and loneliness and abandonment
that came over me during that time
me up my god never forget it
life-changing because that was a moment
for me what someone's like you got to do
something with your life you got to get
the out of here
whoever responsible for you is gone it's
up to you now you got to do what the
you got to do to get out this
situation and ain't have no self esteem
cuz you just took it to the pawnshop cut
the four years later partial basketball
scholarship and I'm selling crack
cocaine what 18 years old and I ain't
the best coke dealer you not me
cuz the person my ogq calling sending me
on weird ass jobs get a phone call like
a man she's checking on some rocks
machine got no money I want you to take
and let her suck your dick she give her
two rocks sigh I do that these
junkies but it was all a lot of anger
because my dad was a junkie you know I
mean so hangover about no other
junkies out there so look at my dicks up
in a Honda Accord for how the grocery
store and it's weird it's weird it's a
weird moment how the did I get here
that was even more weird for her you
know I mean she looked up she was like
sorry faint doing a good job
owning really sucked dick I'm a lesbian
I was like oh crack is addictive
[Applause]
crack is addictive I thought it was on
the person that smoked crack no this
gets a hold on you that's a
powerful hash drop I can't go home
that's a tough situation and I'm gonna
tell you why cuz when I looked up its a
part right there
and at that Park in that basketball
court is a father and son playing
basketball I don't get my dick soft and
it's hunger core trying not to cry the
father and son playing goddamn
basketball that could have been my life
and I can't even look up or down so just
looking out the window trying to find
some inspiration so I can finish I seen
that father-son play ball I've
recognized something that no matter how
much money I made selling crack or how
successful I got I never could buy the
thing that I wanted which was the bond
of a father and son together and that
was one of the last moments you know me
that I decided to seal crack
I came though
[Applause]